pour ces deux demoiselles catherine et
françoise dorléac le tout paris hier
soir avait les yeux de jacques demy car
après les parapluies de cherbourg
il vient de réaliser avec michel legrand
les demoiselles de rochefort
jacques demy vous devenez un spécialiste
de la comédie musicale parce que j'aime
bien ce qui sort des sentiers battus
revel et centimes sont pas intéressants
ce qui est tout à fait fascinant c'est
là c'est de chercher quelque chose de
nouveau
je crois enfin de la tâche dans la
création précisément de faire des choses
différentes et par exemple le film que
j'avais fait précédemment et est un film
plus tôt
grave sérieux et j'avais envie de
trouver un sentiment de joie comme ça
qui fait que le spectateur trouve un
encouragement une une détente à sourire
et voilà en face au début du film on
peut dire que c'est la première comédie
musicale française
je ne sais pas failli des tentatives
quand même se fait vraiment une mais il
ya très longtemps
et enfin vous il y alors ça qu'on n'ait
pas fait de comédie musicale en france
est ce que vous comptez poursuivre avec
avec votre ami michel legrand dans cette
voie je ne sais pas je ne peux pas vous
dire pour l'instant parce que c'est un
tel travail j'ai été longtemps sur ce
sur ce film que maintenant je suis le
vide et sans idées et sans jugement sur
tout et j'ai besoin de faire le point et
puis de réfléchir et puis je sais qu'une
petite mécanique se mettra en route et
que automatiquement je trouverais ce que
j'ai à faire
alors ce sera peut-être un autre musical
effectivement catherine deneuve le matin
comme ça après le triomphal succès du
film hier soir qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est tout vous ressentez est ce que
c'est un petit peu
enfin pour vous avez fêté le succès oui
d'abord parce que le film a commencé
assez tard et qu'ensuite chemin que vous
ne parliez de jacques demy cas vous êtes
l'enfant chéri de jacques demy qu'on va
lui dire que ce n est pas forcément non
j'aimerais que vous me parlez lui comme
c'est quelqu'un de très tendre de traits
de très doux et très violent à la fois
de très sûr de lui le très ambitieux si
quelqu'un qui vient qui aime être au
bord de la mer qu'à vous allez vendre la
mère pour lui je crois d'ailleurs la
maison et marmoutier et souvent et qui a
besoin de voir la mer vous travaillez
aussi c'est pour ça qu'il fait toujours
des films dans les ports